In 1988, I was running my own restaurant and I came down with a severe cough.
And after numerous tests, I got diagnosed with HIV.
Managing the daily tasks required to live well with a chronic disease is challenging.
Sharon Thomas credits much of her success to a cold, wet nose and a warm, fuzzy cuddle.
I can't imagine life without having pets.
I think that that's why God has them here.
Pets can be a wonderful support for adults living with chronic illness.
Allison Webel of the Frances Payne Bolton School of Nursing at Case Western Reserve University...
...led a new study of nearly 50 participants...
...to better understand how women manage their HIV AIDS.
We were really surprised by the central role that pets really seem to have...
...in helping them to manage their day-to-day health tasks,...
...such as adhering to medications and following a healthy lifestyle.
It's someone who kind of gives them a way of organizing their day,...
...so the routine work of feeding the pet and walking the pet...
...and coming home to the pet.
And all of those positive responsibilities lead women to best manage their health.
It's almost vital.
Taking care of the two of them takes care of me automatically.